well as you heard gas and groceries
higher and it's hurting a little more
and it's that time again for us to gift
someone a good day just for that very
reason 8 news now is partnered with
albertsons to help make someone's day
brighter let's take a look
i met tareen at the checkout line at
albertson's on rainbow in charleston
she's currently a caregiver for family
living in her home
i take care of my son who had major
surgery and she was doing something nice
for her next door neighbor who's been
helping her around the house you've got
a gift for your neighbor who's painting
your fence yes i do the neighbor is
wonderful tareen does so much for the
people in her life and now it was time
for her to be rewarded for her kindness
what would you say if i said that eight
news now and albertsons are partnering
together to gift you a good day to help
you out with your oh how wonderful that
would be magnificent would that help you
out
all righty my neighbor
well that might help pay your neighbor
for all my neighbors gift up
how about if we hold your gift up this
is for you oh how wonderful you enjoy
your groceries on us and albert that's
wonderful i love albertsons
i had a pleasure it was such a great
time surprising terrain thanks again to
albertsons for making all this happen
the staff is always so wonderful there
the shoppers are always so friendly so
we have such a good time and you know
it's just so nice to put a smile on
somebody's face tareen was
she was a hoot i have to say i was on
helping her unpack her groceries oh and
so she she was loaded with food she had
i mean she had her cart was loaded with
food
and then she pulled i pulled out this
big bottle of tequila and i'm like wow
and she goes that's for my neighbor
who's painting my fence and i'm trying
to do something nice for him to say
thank you because he won't take payment
and so i was like so she bought the
tequila we bought the groceries that's
the way it all worked out at the
checkout counter wow so
someone's having a wild weekend
tequila have both done these things
where we help people out give them a
good day yeah but i've never helped them
unpack their groceries oh
she's taking care of her son